[Music]
with the release of Captain Marvel less
than a month away fans are slowly stung
to the your eyes exactly what could
happen in the movie based on rumors and
leaks there's a lot of ones that seemed
to hold way and others that seemed
completely impossible
ie goose takes the Infinity Gauntlet
from Thanos and reverses the snap which
better happen and now that I think about
it anyway with so many out on the
internet I decided to put together a
list of the top three theories on the
film to let you know exactly what to
expect when you go to see it in March
there may be some spoilers here so if
you don't want to know anything about
the film at all then I highly suggest
that you turn off now but with that out
the way I'm definition and welcome to
the channel where I ruin it so you don't
have to number one Doctor Strange is in
it this one has saw a lot of coverage in
the past couple of days to the point
that it almost seems like the big movie
journalists know something we don't
the theory states that the post-credits
scene of Captain Marvel will show dr.
strange travelling back in time to warn
Carol Danvers and Nick Fury about the
events of an infinity war he likely
gives away what happens and this is why
Nick Fury holds off ever calling for
Captain Marvel until the events of the
last Avengers film the scene then ends
with strange traveling back to Titan to
deliver his 14 million outcomes line to
Tony Stark and the rest of the group of
the planet but what evidence is there
for this well the Prince of spoilers Tom
Holland himself let's slip in an
interview for infinity war that strange
played by Benedict Cumberbatch had a
couple of lines about the quantum realm
in the film but as these didn't appear
in the movie it seems strange that he
would drop this of course time is money
in the movie business so it would make
more sense to have shot the post-credits
scene for Captain Marvel at the same
time as Infinity Ward so this may have
been where Holland picked up these lines
from obviously Captain Marvel needs to
tie into the larger MCU picture and what
better way to bring her fully up to
speed with just how important it is
take down daños number two the character
can time travel okay so this one has
been pretty much 100% confirmed and it's
pre obvious but I need to bring this up
to talk about the other point in my
video in an interview at the start of
January with Entertainment Tonight when
discussing the film samuel l jackson
stated that she's pretty much the
strongest character in terms of someone
with powers who is able to do things so
for carol danvers to be that person and
for bree to become that person it's
gonna be a dynamite thing I mean the
Avengers are up against some really
really tough odds right now as we saw
throughout infinity war so we know that
we need something that's as powerful as
Thanos and at some point we'll probably
find out how powerful she is and all the
things that she's capable of she's one
of the few people in the Marvel Universe
that can time travel so I don't know
what he said after that it's not
mentioned in the interview but anyway
this clearly confirms that not only can
the character time travel but that there
will be an element of this somewhere in
the movie Jackson like many others was
probably not aware that the character
could do this so for him to bring it up
pretty much confirms that we will
definitely have some time trouble a bend
in her first film also the fact that
Jackson has a pager to show cases that
she has been off somewhere else since
the 90s doing her own thing and finally
number three where has she been all this
time
we know that Captain Marvel is set in
the nineties and by the looks of leaked
shots etc it seems like she's a fully
formed hero by the end of the film so
how does time-travel tie into this and
where has she been well from the
trailers it's pretty clear that Captain
Marvel will be battling the scrolls on
earth in an effort to stop them invading
the scrolls are a shape-shifting race of
aliens that are some of the biggest and
baddest enemies in the Marvel Universe
this means that they are able to blend
in perfectly with modern civilization
and go undetected unless of course
Captain Marvel who can clearly tell when
someone is a scroll from the trailers
takes them down a lot of fans have
theorized that at the end of Captain
Marvel the titular character will travel
off into the quantum
and go through time eliminating
Impostors Kevin Feige has already
confirmed that Captain Marvel will
feature the quantum realm just as much
as ant-man in the wasp did so and makes
sense for this to be the reason why
she's had such a prolonged absence in an
ideal world we will get to post-credit
scenes with the first being the Doctor
Strange cameo that I talked about
earlier and the second being here
arriving just moments after fury paged
her to find that the world is in ruins
from here she could travel back into the
quantum realm discover ant-man and take
him out of it to serve the events of
Avengers end game who knows maybe when
ant-man is knocking on the door of
Avengers HQ she's actually in the scene
with him and is merely being CGI doubt
for the promotion which is something
that Marvel have been famous for in the
past this could be why he utters the
line ant-man I know you know that
could he be referring to the fact that
they know him but not Captain Marvel
well I guess all will be answered when
the film hits theaters but obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the
theories and if you've heard any extra
ones that you think seem legitimate make
sure you leave them in the comments
below and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my other comic book related video
the Umbrella Academy ending explain and
season to predictions which will be
linked at the end this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]